you are in a relationship now yes thank
god thank god my old relationships right
can they all just die
not the people the relationships
the fact that we're irl
is everything you like all over the zoo
yeah let's get together to the podcast
so talk to me about this because
obviously you still have your youtube
channel you're on only fans you started
a perfume you're about to start an
agency like why did you decide you know
what i'm gonna throw a podcast in there
too honestly because i'm a madman
psychopath no one should be doing all of
this but i've wanted a podcast for
so long i feel like when i actually look
at my entire career and i look back
that's like the thing i've wanted
consistently for years like desperately
but there was just always bad deals or
wrong timing or there was definitely a
few years where i would never be able to
show up to something every week and like
get it out there back in the day i would
have been saying that crazy i would have
been sued by the third episode so it's
like
you know what i mean everything happens
for a reason timing wise but i've wanted
it for so long and now i have the best
manager in the world david weintraub and
i was like give me the best podcast and
he was like give me a week tana is the
greatest talent in the world and she is
one person that you are not going to see
get cancelled this project is months and
months of hard work for it to go number
one it's like
it's just i don't i can't i can't
believe it any dream guest
for the podcast any dream guest for the
podcast i have one for you can i picture
yeah i think britney spears should do
the sit down right here oh my god
imagine i break that i would die for her
no question asked i would do anything in
the world forever she knows that for you
if you're watching this i love you so
much i just i just want you to win you
are the best freaking
no yeah i don't know i don't know
everyone keeps asking me i keep jokingly
saying obama but i i really don't know i
don't know i just
the dream guess to me or just whoever's
gonna make a great episode i know that's
such a corny answer i need to think
about it more i think it'd be fun
eventually to maybe have like an x on or
someone i had beef with or you know what
i mean like a feud like that that would
be crazy crazier than and interviewing
anyone would you ever have jake on just
so i he'd answer me and i could yell at
him sure
i'm just kidding
babe um we yeah we're not on the
greatest terms but stay gorgeous you
know we all have those
those those exes he's yeah oh yeah
cheers to that one can we talk about the
tick tock that he made where he said he
fake married a slob he called me
every time i think about it i'm just
like i was actually debating on
responding back just hanging from a tree
like eating leaves like actually acting
like a sloth um
everyone thought i was talking about his
dick size and i was i was talking about
the fact that i'm this close to a video
like alyssa violets because i you know
obviously that's really infuriating when
you do even if you look at what happened
differently than i do like you know i
really loved you and i did everything
for you and like there was a time where
no one was there for you and i was and
like
i just i don't i don't think it's a very
nice way to act clearly you're a little
pissed about some but i just i look at a
lot of the time we spend together and i
never thought we'd be in a place like
this and i can't lie if i say it doesn't
hurt me and upset me so that's just the
truth but would you be willing to make
an amends because of your past with him
i'm [ __ ] pissed okay maybe not right
now i'm just kidding i'm just kidding
it's obviously you know when you like
love someone for that long i'm not
saying that feeling was mutual clearly
he thinks i miss lost so god knows but i
mean
it's you know it's a given that you will
always want the best for them and if
this is how he wants to be and it's the
best then
stay gorgeous baby girl you're in a
relationship now yeah thank god thank
god my old relationships right can they
all just die
so we're not the people the
relationships so what are you getting
out of this relationship with chris that
you've never had before oh well i mean
chris is just actually a perfect sweet
human and he loves me so much and what's
actually dope about chris and i i think
is that we are such similar people like
our senses of humor are the same the way
we like live and act and are are the
same and like we just have so much in
common in that sense that i can spend
like every second with him because it's
not like i'm living someone else's life
you know yeah or like i'm trying to like
love what someone else loves it's like
we actually just have all of the same
interests and like
just get along so well together it's
it's funny because obviously he's my
boyfriend but i look at him like sitting
around with all my friends and i'm like
he fits into the friend group as if he
was just like everyone's best friend as
well which i think is dope and he's just
like he's the most loving sweet human so
that's so yeah
does it feel like it could be long long
term like uh i mean girl it's me
like
let's be real uh i think but what i also
like about us is we do kind of take it
day by day we talked for six months
before we dated i wanted to really like
take time
take it slowly and take it day by day
and just have fun and like be young
because that's what we are and that's
how we are together so don't over think
you're right of course like obviously
when you're with someone you hope it it
lasts long and things are good but i
like taking things day by day now
because i've definitely gotten very
ahead of myself in a lot of
relationships right absolutely think
about kids and [ __ ] like [ __ ] shut up
you don't that's the last thing you want
and when those expectations are up here
already exactly
give yourself the time to get there
exactly and then it goes that's so true
that's literally so true it's like a
ladder
oh my god no [ __ ] maybe you should be
my therapist
obviously we've seen you go through so
much with your past relationships
including bella including jake how did
each of those relationships kind of
shape you
it's funny because i look back sometimes
i'm like i wish i never met that person
to them both i'm like
no i'm kidding um but like
um no but like you know what i mean
you'll be angry and you'll look back on
a relationship okay i wish i never met
that person but then you think like that
period of life
like taught me so [ __ ] much about
myself and about myself in relationships
too i look at the way i handle with
chris now and i'm like sometimes i'll
like go out of body and pat myself in
the back i'm like but you were being so
emotionally mature you would have never
done this in the past all of those
people taught me a lot a lot of things
and it's i was literally talking with my
best friend hunter this morning like
it's so weird to think for like years of
our life we would be at bellathorne's
house every day kicking it with her like
now i could never imagine that but at
the time i was so happy and she taught
me so much about being a free better
person this is the first nice thing i've
said about bella in like eight years um
that's that's how you can tell i'm
coming out of it same thing with jake
i'm not in the place to say anything too
nice but
you know exact time does heal yeah and
it
all of those periods of life taught me
so [ __ ] much to the point that it's
like yeah i love who i am now but even
sometimes i wish i could just erase it
all and be a celibate nun who's never
been with anyone it all happens for a
reason but it all leads you to the right
person sincerely you know so can i ask
you this what's chris reaction when you
posted tick tock making out with demi
lovato
chris is all for it are you kidding me
are you kidding me he's very like
accepting of me being like wild
especially when i like i think he's you
know he's a rapper he's like of course
you should that like the hot ass
[ __ ] you know what i mean like
he's like down for dope [ __ ] like that
and like demi
is such a [ __ ] awesome person too
chris just knows how much i adored emmy
so it's like he i think he was holding
the flashlight for us to film that one
that was my question yeah